نعم ازدهار اينما وليت وجهك او اينما وليت
عدسه الكاميرا في اي منطقه من مدينه رفح
تجد اوجه جديده من الماساه والمعاناه التي
يعيشها سواء سكان المدينه او اكثر من
مليون ونصف فلسطيني يعيشون في هذه المدينه
الضي الضيقه نحن نتواجد هنا في منطقه مواص
رفح بالقرب من شاطئ بحر مدينه رفح هذه كما
تشاهدون خيام بسيطه جدا من
النيل حدثنا النازحون هنا انهم طيله ساعه
دقيقه واحده المياه غمرت هذه المنطقه
الرياح العاتيه اقتلعت هذه الخيام
البسيطه الاطفال هنا لا توجد ملابس شتويه
تقيهم هذا البرد القارس وهذه الرياح
العاتيه في هذه المنطقه ايضا بالكاد تكاد
تصمد هذه الخيام امام صمود النازحين في
هذه المنطقه وفي هذه الاجواء البارده جدا
اطفال ونساء وشيوخ
ومرضى الجميع يواجه معاناه وماساه انسانيه
كبيره في هذه المنطقه في منطقه موا رفع
حتى من شده الرياح وعوده الامطار هطولها
مجددا بالكاد نستطيع ان نتحدث معكم فما
بالكم من يعيش منذ اكثر من 60 او 70 يوما
في هذه المنطقه هنا ايضا اتت عائلات من
مدينه خان يونس باتت ليلتها الماضيه في
العراء لم تجد خيمه لم تجد فراش لم تجد
ملابس شتويه لاطفالهم لم يجدون ادنى
مقومات حياه كانوا يبحثون عن قطعه قماش او
نايلون لكي تقيهم من برد الشتاء وزخات
المطر الشديده التي كانت طيله ساعات
الليل هذه خيمه بسيطه من من
النيلون توجد داخلها
عائله كما
تشاهدون ب على الفحم
يخبزون اطفال
ونساء
و واوضاع صعبه
للغايه هذه الخيمه تؤوي اكثر من 10 افراد
ضيقه جدا 14 نفر يحدثني رب الاسره بالكاد
ينامون فيها في ساعات
الليل هي مكونه من
النايلون
البسيط دون توفر ادنى
مقومات للحياه او للاستقرار
في ظل اجواء قاسيه جدا وفي ظل
اوضاع مؤمن الصوره ابلغ من الويه في هذه
المنطقه ماذا عن المساعدات من المعروف بان
مراكز الاواء رب على الاونر وغيرها من
المنظمات الانسانيه قد تصلهم النازحين الى
مدارسها ومراكزها لواء قد تصلهم بعض
المساعدات ماذا بالنسبه لهذه المناطق التي
استحدث الناس لانفسهم فيها مخيما وصنعوا
ربما لانفسهم فيها خيام بسيطه ومتواضعه
للبقاء هل تصلهم اي من المساعدات هل تصلهم
هذه المنظمات او
مساعداتها
امام تدفق الزهار الكبير للاعداد الكبيره
من النازحين من مختلف المناطق واخ واخرها
عشرات الالاف من العائلات من مدينه خان
يونس تحت وطاه القصف والغارات الاسرائيليه
مراكز الاواء ممتلئه عن بكره ابيها في
مدينه رفع سواء المدارس التابعه للاونروا
او فروع مقرات للجامعات او حتى المؤسسات
الحكوميه حتى من يتواجد داخل مدارس
الاونور رصدنا صباح اليوم عدد من العائلات
اتخذت من سلم من الدرج درج المدرسه ماوا
لها يبيت الاطفال والنساء والمرضى على درج
المدرسه لعدم توفر اي غرف او حتى خيام
يستقرون بها العدد الكبير والهائل ودفع
جيش الاحتلال جميع سكان قطاع غزه للنزوح
لهذه المنطقه الجغرافيه الضيقه مدينه رفح
لا تستطيع لا المنظمات الاغاثه الدوليه
ولا المحليه الفلسطينيه الت مع هذه
الاعداد الكبيره في ظل
محدوديه المساعدات التي تدخل الى قطاع غزه
عبر معبر رفح البري سواء مساعدات من ناحيه
الخيام من ناحيه المساعدات التموينيه
والغذائيه بكل معنى الحرفي للكلمه عندما
نقول ان عائلات تجوع في غزه بالفعل هناك
عائلات تجوع في مدينه غزه وفي رفح في جميع
انحاء القطاع نتيجه عدم توفر الدقيق نتيجه
عن توفر الغذاء نتيجه فما بالك في الادويه
المستلزمات الطبيه 70% من المساعدات
الطبيه التي تدخل لقطاع غزه حسب المكتب
الاعلام الحكومي انها خارج خارج احتياجات
واولويات الصحيه لعلاج الالاف من الجرحى
حتى ان بعض شحنات المساعدات الطبيه التي
اتت ودخلت عبر معبر رفح للاسف الشديد كانت
العلاج وباء كورونا فاضطرت وزاره الصحه
استغناء عن هذه المساعدات التي جاءت وهي
تطالب بضروره تلبيه الاحتياجات الانسانيه
الاساسيه لجنه الطوارئ هنا في مدينه رفح
تقول انها بحاجه على الاقل ل 50,000 خيمه
لواء العائلات التي تنزح الى مدينه رفح
حتى ان مراكز الاواء امتلات عن بكره ابيه
تشاهدون في الصوره من الصفيح من النيلون
من القماش من الخشب البسيط يحاولون ايواء
اطفالهم ونسائهم وبناتهم
لكن وعوره الطقس واشتداد مع اشتداد الحرب
والقصف الاسرائيليه تزيد من بلاء وماساه
مئات الالاف من العائلات التي نزحت هنا
الى مدينه رفح في ظل اوضاع انسانيه اقل ما
يقال عنها انها كارثيه للغايه الاطفال في
هذه
المنطقه حفاه بدون احذيه حتى ان الناس
يقولون انه يتدبرون امرهم من ناحيه الطعام
سواء وجبه واحده في اليوم الاطفال لا توجد
ملابس شتويه لا توجد احذيه انا شهدت في كل
المناطق التي تجولت فيها صباح اليوم في
مدينه رفح الكثير من الاطفال حفاه بدون
احذيه في ظل هذا الجو الماطر والبارد فما
بالك في ال الشيوخ المصابين بامراض مزمنه
مرضى السرطان 100 الا مريض سرطان في قطاع
غزه لا يجد حبه دواء واحده منذ بدء الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه ولا يسمح لهم بال
لتلقي العلاج في الخارج ايضا وضع كارثي
للغايه في مدينه رفح المدينه بحاجه الى
كميات كبيره من المساعدات وبحاجه الى
ادخال الخيام والادويه والغذاء ايضا وكان
الله في عون غزه شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل
الجزيره من رفح مؤمن اشرافي